more than a million voters have switched
the republican party in the last 24 in
the last 12 months
and that's a big number including tens
of thousands of swing vote voters and
some declaring they can no longer
support the democratic party policies
according to report monday the move to
the gop is occurring in every part of
the country
in democratic and republican states and
cities since president biden defeated
former president trump and analysis of
voter registration data by associated
press found over the past year about
two-thirds of 1.7 million voters who
changed party affiliation shifted to the
republican party and overall more than 1
million people become republicans
compared to 630 000 who became democrats
why do you think that is
uh the as i think it was james carville
said it's the economy stupid i mean yeah
it's gas i think it's that simple yes i
i really do you had a boom economy you
had the most robust economy in our
history under trump you had uh record
job growth record wage growth billions
of dollars coming back in the country to
be invested here
you had an optimism in the country
people's businesses at the small
business level doing extraordinarily
well
now you have apprehension about gas
prices about food shortages
rampant inflation i mean i went to
publix the other day and i bought a
steak
the steak cost me seven and a half bucks
it was four bites it was the smallest
state i've ever seen in my entire life
so uh yeah i i think that that has a lot
to do with it i think that there are
there's no question that there are
buyer's remorse substantial number of
people who
voted for biden because they didn't like
trump's style
oh he's so crude his tweets are so crude
yeah but how's how's your business oh my
business is doing great so uh i think
that's this is the manifestation of that
you think people are starting to realize
that and process it where they're saying
okay listen i can't publicly say this
but i i kind of wish the other guy was
president right now you know minus the
stuff that he was doing on twitter i'm
willing to tolerate him more than i'm
willing to tolerate joe or are people
saying there's no way in the world that
could support somebody like him uh
they're both at this point extremely
polarizing figures
uh but i do think that there is a there
is certain some nostalgia for trump's
economy that that is for sure what would
you say biden has done right has biden
gotten anything right since he became
president
you can't think of anything what about
the new gun laws that have been passed
what about the um
uh infrastructure bill none of that i
think the infrastructure bill was first
of all has nothing to do with
infrastructures has to do with spending
it's one of the reasons why we have the
inflation we have today i think red flag
laws are unconstitutional it's just my
opinion
you want to weigh in on this right a
little bit i i first of all i totally
agree with you i think the american
people vote sometimes for charisma but
at the end of the day you're going to
vote with your wallet
the average american cannot make ends
meet anymore
whether they were
democrat or republican before
this is something that you know our
survival is our family and how do you
take care of your family
if gas is five dollars a gallon
so for for that for that part i totally
agree with you on the on the gun stuff
um
that is such a political football uh and
it shouldn't be because you've got to
look at the real facts
every city that has the highest crime
rate in the united states
also has the strongest
anti-gun laws
then you go to places like wyoming
montana even florida and some in some
areas and crime is down
because people can defend themselves
you know that that combination uh
you were talking about
biden doing something right let me tell
you something that i think that it is
borders on the ridiculous
you go from
saying that crime is rampant
you're allowing crime to be go rampant
you're not persecuting
criminals you're releasing them this is
a catch and release i can fishing
and
how do you how does that make sense to
anybody
defund the police so you're telling me
that you who do not like guns and are
not willing or able to take care of
yourself who are you going to rely on
the police
and you're voting
for to defund your safety net that's
like buying a parachute on ebay
what about you pat is there anything
that you can find uh compelling with
biden these days i know you've been
pretty vocal you're not exactly a biting
guy but
you you you do have the ability to
reason you're not like
set in your uh
views but so you guys
unbiased so let me tell you how and this
this is going to sound like
this but it's not the less i see the
president the more excited i am
i don't want to see the president
because to me it's like stay away go to
show up and lead don't get up and
complain so
the benefit of him not being comfortable
on stage speaking is a good thing
because we don't hear him often so he's
not out there talking all the time
which is a good thing because when he
does talk america doesn't look good when
he talks would you be comfortable if you
found out that maybe susan rice or
barack obama are kind of
pulling the strings behind the scenes
would you be comfortable with that
so you're asking policies if you're
asking policies i don't support his
policies
i don't support what policies he's got
in place because i don't think his
policies are advancing people by the way
a million votes to voters to flip flip
from what that means democrats became
republicans what are we talking about
here i mean that's not a small number by
the way well and pat if you think about
that break down that number that's just
a broad number where are they coming
from they're coming from the latino
community and the black community
joe biden is losing black support he is
losing latino support the base of the
democratic party is flipping they they
are going to lose everything if they
keep this up this is right this is the
greatest significant realignment for the
first time in the country ever
hispanics say they split down the middle
republican democrat that's never
happened before
and the reality is
that under trump you had the highest
rate of job growth and wage growth among
african americans the lowest
unemployment rates and you had criminal
justice reform the first step act the
second chance act so things that the
democrats had talked about
but never enacted
look the the the people i know though
who are hispanic or african-american the
parents
of the people i knew when i was in the
military they were all conservative
all of them were like hey son are you
reading the bible are you doing this
are you saying this are you saying that
they were very much conservatives who
were expecting you to be a good man and
not break the law not do this stuff same
with hispanics
uh
but some of them have been sold a bag of
goods that's not working you know what i
like you you know what i do like on
what's going on
is on the roe v way topic which we'll
get into here in a minute is where
people
on the left got upset with kamala harris
to say this is why you need to vote for
us and this is why elections matter and
they said wait a minute
you can do anything you want to do right
now you're not so we voted for you to
get things done and nothing's getting
done so no elections don't matter you
keep telling us to give more money a
democrat was out there
uh this was a video that went viral i
don't know if you saw this or not she
says i'm out here protesting
about roe v wade
and this happened under the watch of a
democratic president who i voted for
and five minutes before i came out here
protesting i got an email from joe biden
and kamala harris telling me to give 15
bucks i've been given 15
but you're not doing anything with my
money how much more money should i give
you so
when your own party turns against you
you got a big problem here and a million
is a big number so if you're asking me
that question
that's a big number we're talking so
address that whatever that person is
they probably just don't understand how
the supreme court works because trump
put in what three justices during his
tenure which is uh no one's ever done
it's not like it's not like
or come along you don't need control
over the supreme court you're right but
what what what okay so go go with that
go with that what did biden promised to
his voters
are you talking about packing the court
no no
go what did biden so people who voted
for trump okay
what did trump promise to people that he
did
what did trump promise what it what was
trump's promise to his voters that he
said if you elect me i'm going to do xyz
what's going to make america great again
he's going to laugh he's going to build
the wall
a lot of three-word phrases
he's going to revive the economy he's
going to rebuild our military he's going
to point conservatives to the judiciary
correct uh he's going to he's going to
negotiate better trade deals everything
he said those things he did those things
what did biden say i'm going to raise
taxes okay mm-hmm i'm gonna he hasn't
raised
back better he's gonna be he has to go
back better he's gonna re-enter the
paris uh accords he did that okay so you
got one on his party so i'm just i'm
just thinking of whatever i get that but
i mean he wanted to increase um
multilateralism you know re-engage with
nato obviously trump wasn't a big fan of
nato making them pay yeah
clearly things with nato seem to be
doing a little bit better these days
especially with
the war in ukraine i mean at least
the g7 is on the same page it seems
against russia
what else okay so what you're you got a
party another person's got a party you
vote for your guy it's percentage right
if your policies you say 10 things
you're going to be doing if 80 of them
you do
then the other party elects a guy and
out of 10 things he said he's going to
do he does three of them that's a free
throw percentage 80 wins yeah trump did
more of what he said he was going to do
than biden did what he said he was going
to i agree with you and if and if we
take
cove it out you're president today's
trump by the way you're not wrong i
agree with you here's here's the problem
and i've said this a million times and
and roger stone maybe want to weigh in
on this
trump didn't
lose the election because of
bad policies
it was because of his bad personality
and america was over it straight up we
can we can kind of tap dance around his
personality all we want but what makes
him charismatic to some
makes him unappealing to others not his
policies you could go down the list boom
boom boom boom and if you if you ask
most americans about policies but by the
way most americans could not elaborate
on most policies like you said james
carville
let me let me push you people let me
push the economy let me challenge you on
that real quick okay so this is the one
so we're having dinner two nights ago
with a guy heart you know who he is
heart and his wife and we're having
dinner with gaines
and andrew and jennifer and i'm sitting
there and i'm bringing up issues to them
like so so let me ask you a question
with such and such thing that clarence
thomas wants to how do you feel about it
how do you feel about transgender how do
you feel about this how do you feel
about that
well you know to each his own and all
this other stuff and i said really yeah
said okay cool i said at what point did
you form this opinion of to each his own
i don't know i said 20 years ago would
you have said to each his own
uh well yeah
no i don't know i said look here's what
happens
do not let the majority of people the
minority of people who are allowed to
convince you they're the majority so
here's what happened the minority of
people who are complainers
they're they're like this they come and
fight you in the street and they go like
this you want to fight let me tell you
who i got i got 200 people back to
around the building if you want to fight
i'm going to come and kick your ass and
they're going to come and whoop your ass
and like oh [ __ ] they got 200 people
back there so what do you do you're like
dude i don't want to fight these guys
and then you go home right and you go
around the corner they got nobody
they convinced the world they had 200
people around the corner ready to fight
for them so because they're louder
complainers they have convinced even fox
news to do special on transgender
calling that family what an honorable
thing to do what a brave family here
people are falling for
all of these things to say well if
everybody else says it's okay maybe i
should say it as well where the hell is
your backbone or maybe you disagree
and if you disagree people may sit there
and say
i can't believe you said this i come no
problem go for it you can come at me i'm
totally okay with that but this is my
position i'm uncomfortable with it good
for you would agree with the crowd i'm
not agreeing with the crowd so if we do
go back
and we ask the question of many people
didn't feel comfortable with trump okay
many people didn't feel comfortable with
desantis is it true many people didn't
or is it the fact that the people who
said many people didn't are the loudest
complainers and we believe that there
are many people but there's only a few
that's the question and i think people
are starting to realize today when you
see a million people flipping maybe
there were not many people so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]